Qua chính đàn phang giống Mỹ về Iran về thoát thật nhân tiết tục có sĩnh bị mới,
sau khi tổng thống Mỹ đoàn trọng yêu cộng sự đời một số nổi giống trong dự thảo thật với Iran.
Theo các quần chức cấp cao trong chính quyền Mỹ trở biết,
tổng thống xam bay tò mỗi sớm đạt được một thoát thòn, nhưng trong rằng các tăng cường giữ điều khoản,
là bị linh qua nếu mật liệu học nhé của Iran và cơ chế kiểm soát về làm giáo uống ra đi.
Tổng thống Mỹ đo chá là chỉ chất nhận một thảo thòn mang lại lựa ý cho Mỹ,
và bao giờ Mỹ và thông thị sử vô vô kiét nhân,
yêu cộng sự đổi đã mở ra điểm phòng thương lượng mới,
giữ các bên dự kiến cáo xa thêm phải ngày.
Chuy nông nhà nước Iran cho biết,
Te Iran chưa phê chuẩn và bản quay cung,
trái với một số thông tin trường đoàn tự phía Mỹ,
cho rằng Iran đã sáng sản thị kết,
theo các quần tên,
mà nên mà lại từ gió hành 2 quay bên hoặc ngốc cũng năm trong nhóm lộ dương lưu đu dự trình,
giúp tin trình bị cáo xa các quần chương Mỹ và tính xa trên vọc,
con tuy thuộc và phản hội của Te Iran và tin trình thương lượng tiếp theo.